[Music]
million shows on TV one thing I find
very helpful is that little info button
on the cable remote you know brings up
the screen it tells you what you need to
know about the show you're squatching I
thought we'd take a look at something
and the info button results in a
peaceful call what am i watching they're
not my body
that's alright again not my body right
it's completely whose body is it that
guy's dead now is it I don't know it is
it's not my body
it's all wrong it shows longer than your
torso ribs or something
yes it's a longer torso it looks more
male yeah
watching Dateline and then I hit this
button Congrats America China's not
beating us in spouse killings that's a
real person who's dead and we're
laughing what if she had it coming all
right let's go shark tank this one might
be the dead one no there's no way it's
that they showed the woman in an angelic
white and the guy was like a creep
there's no way you can always tell by
the diffusion yeah hers got the
diffusion yes and it's always they were
the light of everyone's life yeah yeah
she was the greatest she was the best
person she doesn't he was the spark in
our lives never like yeah she was all
right too bad she got murdered yeah we
remember most about him I don't remember
her too well and she was real quiet and
stuff I don't know sometimes she could
be obnoxious yeah I live with her that's
true I don't wish she was dead but yeah
it's not she did shoplift a lot
she farted constant yeah they should do
a murder so called Matt terrible rosacea
yeah she was 102 it was her time could
be murdered she was mean and old and
then she was murdered
she had nothing left to contribute and
then he entered her life and her story
was pretty much told and she was a drain
on society and then he came and took it
all away the judges hands were tied he
had to find him guilty didn't want to oh
man god I want to see that show cuz
let's face it man the Matt murder the
mass murders I'm Bill Curtis welcome to
the back I'm not saying they deserve to
die I'm just saying man he was 68 and
attacks t he never had a job and he said
realize things at parties then you know
suddenly rob from us the murderer killed
him quickly and quietly so that he
didn't suffer
[Music]
you